bonsoir voici les titres de l'actualité
de ce 27 avril
en corse le rétablissement de l'état de
droit mis en cause après les
emprisonnements de trois gendarmes dont
un colonel mis en examen pour la
destruction par explosif d'un restaurant
près d'ajaccio
à belgrade le vice premier ministre vu
qu'ils brassent gritche affirme que son
pays est prêt à accueillir une force de
l'onu au kosovo scepticisme du côté de
l'otan qui poursuit ses frappes
nous serons notamment en albanie permis
des enfants réfugiés
aidé par l'unicef l'inquiétude des
parents d'élèves de charente maritime
après l'incendié du collège de royan
d'établissement type pailleron a mis
moins de deux heures pour brûler il
existe beaucoup d'autres collèges de ce
type encore utilisé du sport football
demi finale de coupe de france demain
soir entre nantes et nîmes l'occasion
d'évoquer ce que l'on appelle l'école
nantaise de football en corse depuis
plus d'un an depuis l'assassinât du
préfet erignac tout était basé
officiellement sur le rétablissement de
l'état de droit
mais depuis hier soir il s'agit surtout
du droit de savoir pour le savoir
pourquoi des gendarmes auraient
participé à la destruction par explosif
d'une paillote situé sur une plage près
d'ajaccio
trois gendarmes dont un colonel ont été
placés en détention après avoir été mis
en examen et leurs supérieurs
le préfet bernard bonnet a été convoqué
en urgence à paris
récit dominique verdeilhan rapide
aller-retour est lourde journée pour le
préfet de corse
souriant le voici ce soir s'apprêtant à
embarquer pour un vol paris ajaccio
souriant mais muet comment faire
c'est apparemment un commentaire
souriant toujours le voici ce matin
débarquant à orly l'homme est attendu
par jean pierre chevènement pour des
explications plus bavard que ce soir
bernard bonnet se déclarent abasourdis
je suis fois triste et abasourdie
pourquoi abasourdi parce que tu as fait
vraiment stupéfiante
c'est très choquant qu'on pensait que
pour l'état de droit c'est quoi il faut
voir comment
si les faits sont établis je suis
tellement majorique bernar venet passera
deux heures place beauvau au ministère
de l'intérieur l'entretien avec jean
pierre chevènement durera près d'une
heure cet après midi le préfet bonnet a
été reçu à matignon par des conseillers
du premier ministre
au même moment jean pierre chevènement
au sénat renouveler la confiance du
gouvernement au successeur du préfet
claude erignac
rien ne permet en tout cas pas 6
antécédents à maître sollacaro de
demander la démission du préfet bernard
bonnet qui s'est acquitté avec courage
et avec détermination de la mission qui
lui était confiée par le gouvernement
seule la justice aujourd'hui peut faire
la lumière
une justice qui pour l'instant ne croit
pas à la version des trois gendarmes ces
derniers se disent victimes d'une
machination d'un traquenard
le juge d'instruction les a mises en
examen puis écroué trois hommes
autrement dit un lieutenant et un
adjudant chef mise en examen pour
destructions volontaires par incendies
mais aussi leur supérieur hiérarchique
le colonel henry mazères poursuivi pour
complicité
cet après midi le colonel a été victime
d'un malaise cardiaque à la maison
d'arrêt de borgo près de bastia dès hier
soir le procureur de la république
évoqué des charges graves contre les
trois gendarmes rassemble un certain
nombre de présomptions qui ont justifié
cette mise en examen
la décision qui a été prise un quatrième
homme le capitaine norbert ambrosse
présent le soir des faits actuellement
hospitalisé à toulouse il pourrait être
transféré demain en corse pour être lui
aussi mis en examen
la paillote chez francis la voici filmé
par l'équipe d'envoyé spécial
construites sans permis elle était visée
comme d'autres par un arrêté de
démolition ordonnée par le préfet la
paillote la voici le matin du 20 avril
ravagé par un incendie criminel
cet après midi au cours d'une conférence
de presse le propriétaire de
l'établissement exhibe elle traque
trouvait sur les lieux
son avocat lui s'interrogeait sur les
responsabilités en haut lieu
nous ce qu'on voudrait savoir c'est qui
a donné l'ordre parce que ces trois
gendarmes si brillant soit-il ont reçu
un ordre mais qui a donné l'ordre
si on arrive à effectivement les uns et
les autres à savoir qui a donné l'ordre
va coûter une page une page extrêmement
saumâtre et une page nauséabonde de
l'histoire de corse va tourner et demain
devrait être une journée plus calme
pour bernard bonnet il sera à bastia où
pierre joxe président de la cour des
comptes présidera une audience de la
chambre régionale des comptes
alors bien sûr les mouvements
nationalistes corses ne se sont pas
privé d'ironiser sur ces mises en examen
des gendarmes et sur la personnalité du
préfet bonnet allant jusqu'à évoquer les
ingrédients d'un mini rainbow warrior en
faisant allusion au fiasco de
l'opération menée il ya 15 ans en
nouvelle-zélande par le
contre-espionnage français pour le reste
les réactions corse évoque avec fatalité
ces événements reportage olivier théron
diane richard les corses sont en quête
de repères
explications trois gendarmes dont le
colonel mazères en détention pour les
motifs habituel des poseurs de bombes
ça a de quoi déstabiliser le préfet
bonnet qui doit s'expliquer à paris
alors même que depuis l'assassinât du
préfet erignac
il se veut le garant de l'état de droit
en corse ça a de quoi déboussoler samcon
ensemble que le gendarme
en examen ou on voit à qui croire
pour m'en faire si les fautifs en prison
comme tout le monde on met les ministres
présents à peu mettre le préfet à tous
les adversaires du préfet bonnet de ces
méthodes s'engouffre dans le climat de
soupçon
l'avocat du propriétaire de la paillote
demande lui sa démission
l'autorité naturelle du gps c'est la
préfecture c'est le préfet bonnet je
pense que dans cette affaire il doit
assumer
sinon sa culpabilité au moins ses
responsabilités ils ont besoin de leçons
en explosifs se moquent les
nationalistes pour qui les troubles de
ces derniers jours son pain béni alors
ils distribuent des tracts dans la rue
et dénoncent déjà un crime d'état
nous avons la satisfaction d'avoir la
concrétisation en dix ans depuis un
certain nombre d'années monde accusant
certains servi d'être à l'origine de
certains attentats et nous en avons
aujourd'hui la preuve parce que gps
s'est fait prendre sur la cancha de la
période à partir de là tout est possible
la demande est à penser qu'il sanctionne
très durement ce que son rôle de
responsable de ses actes à commencer par
lui-même d'ailleurs et ensuite d'une
gangrène que ce type de politique en
corse on ne peut plus jouer et ne peut
que le mettre au ban des nations
les partis de gauche dénonce aussi bien
sur l' incendie de la paillote mais il
ne jugerons que lorsque la justice aura
fait son travail sur l'île en tout cas
les interrogations se nourrissent
maintenant de toutes les rumeurs
ironie des nationalistes se fait
d'autant plus vive que les méthodes du
préfet bernard bonnet ont été radical
sans concession depuis son arrivée à
ajaccio on se souvient de ses réponses
aux élus nationalistes sur sa
détermination à lutter contre les
raquettes et les attentats enquête
michèle fines et claude dernier à chacun
de ses déplacements en corse le préfet
bernard bonnet est entouré de gardes du
corps
les gendarmes du groupe de pelotons de
sécurité cette unité d'élite 95 homme a
été créé en juin 98 5 mois après
l'installation du préfet bonnet
protection intervention renseignements
filature les missions du gps sont
multiples et pour le moins obscures
c'est un lieutenant et un adjudant chef
de cette unité qui ont été placés cette
nuit sous mandat de dépôt depuis son
arrivée sur l'île après l'assassinât du
préfet erignac bernard bonnet s'appuie
essentiellement sur l'action des
gendarmes
bon qu'est ce qu'on a d'autres des
attentats qui ont beaucoup diminué que
je vois les attentats par explosifs -83%
patron de la gendarmerie en corse
le colonel henry mazères écroué lui
aussi hier soir le colonel mazères est
arrivé sur l'île peu de temps après
bernard bonnet presse février 98
une semaine après l'assassinât de claude
erignac le ministre de l'intérieur
installe officiellement le nouveau
pressé la mission de bernard bonnet est
simple rétablir l'état de droit en corse
pour cela il a carte blanche choisi le
cerisier
la seule peur qu'on peut avoir c'est de
ne pas être à la hauteur de la mission
qui peuvent assumer larmes de bernard
bonnet est simple c'est l'article 40 qui
oblige tout détenteur de l'autorité
publique a dénoncé des infractions en un
an
l'ensemble des marchés publics de l'île
est passée au peigne fin pour une
subvention disparu le maire de propriano
et milwaukee et traduits en justice
enfin et surtout bernard bonnet
s'attaque au domaine public maritime
tous les ports privés tout les paillotes
construit dans l'illégalité sont en
passe d'être rasé la politique de l'état
de droit ne plaît pas à tout le monde un
peu partout en corse
des voix s'élèvent les plus fortes sont
celles des nationalistes en avant qu'une
seule question à vous poser monsieur le
préfet elle ne s'adresse pas à l'homme
bien entendu cette question est simple
quand comptez-vous partir je partirai
quand vos amis cesseront le racket
je partirai quand vos amis c'est seront
assassinés dans les fêtes de village je
partirai quand vos amis cesseront de
déposer des explosifs
c'est en quelque sorte le paradoxe de la
société corse
après un an d'état de droit les
nationalistes ont fait 15 % aux
dernières élections territoriales
ils ont gagné des voix quant au préfet
symbole de l'application de la loi
il est aujourd'hui plus que jamais
fragilisée
à paris à l'assemblée nationale dans
l'opposition réclame le droit à la
vérité tout comme du côté du parti
socialiste
à noter que michel charasse le sénateur
socialiste puy-de-dôme soulignait je le
cite le crime profite à ceux qui sont
contre le rétablissement de l'état de
droit et pour le départ du préfet bonnet
ça sent le traquenard
reportage à l'assemblée nationale avec
javits ambert et jean-françois chevet
mais cette fois ne s'est pas le cas du
jour en effet paul quilès résume
l'ambiance du jour la corse a pris
aujourd'hui la première place des
commentaires et des polémiques la droite
tenue au consensus à propos du kosovo se
rattrape le préfet bonnet en prend pour
son grade
servez que lorsqu'il s'exprimait à
l'assemblée de corse le préfet était
beaucoup plus assuré qu'il ne l'est
maintenant et on voit que cette espèce
de tartarin qui faisait des rodomontades
sur les terroristes
absents abassourdi suivant son terme au
premier la première difficulté au
premier coup de canon
quand des policiers des magistrats ou
des gendarmes entreprennent de faire des
coups tordus
y a plus d'état de droit il ya plus de
protection du droit pour les citoyens
l'opposition demande des comptes elle
évoque déjà l'idée d'une commission
d'enquêté parlementaire et interpelle le
gouvernement gendarmes ne peut pas avoir
pris sur lui quel que soit son niveau
dans la hiérarchie
la responsabilité d'une action aussi
absurde et est aussi odieuses et donc le
gouvernement est le premier responsable
de la gendarmerie de la coordination des
forces de police en corse
il lui appartient aujourd'hui au premier
ministre en particulier de nous livrer
toute la vérité sur cette affaire
trop peu d'éléments sont encore connus
réplique prudente de la majorité
plurielle
à gauche on préfère attend la justice
est saisie il faut laisser la justice
faire son travail
remarquez quand même une chose qu'elle
n'a pas perdu de temps alors que nous
sommes dans une région la corse ou ceux
qui parlent aujourd'hui beaucoup ont
parfois fait preuve le certaine
complaisance c'est le moins qu'on puisse
dire avec ceux qui bafouent est chaque
jour l'état de droit le préfet bonnet
venu aujourd'hui à matignon sans voir
lionel choses pas lui-même discret le
premier ministre s'expliquera demain
devant les députés
bernard bonnet vient d'arriver à ajaccio
michele finn vous étiez dans le même
avion est ce qu'on peut faire un premier
bilan de ce voyage de cet aller retour
de monsieur bernard bonnet un premier
bilan oui bernard bonnet est arrivé il
ya moins de cinq minutes
il vient juste de poser les pieds à
ajaccio il a été aussi par les membres
du corps préfectoral de corse du sud ce
qui était une manière de le soutenir de
lui rendre hommage
nous avons été quelques journalistes à
pouvoir le voir dans l'avion au pouvoir
discuter avec lui je peux vous dire que
nous l'avons vu nous l'avons trouvé
particulièrement serein et je dirais
revigoré revigoré pourquoi parce
qu'apparemment l'entrevue qu'il a eu une
entrevue d'une heure qu'il a eu ce matin
avec jean pierre chevènement au
ministère de l'intérieur s'est
particulièrement bien passé elle s'est
bien passée au point que jean pierre
chevènement dans la dans l'après midi a
fait un un communiqué au sénat a dit au
sénat que il ne voyait pas pourquoi on
demanderait au préfet bonnet de
démissionner ce que j'ai cru comprendre
c'est que clairement le préfet bonnet
avait souhaité être soutenu publiquement
dans cette affaire être soutenu par le
ministre de l'intérieur et par
l'ensemble du gouvernement afin de ne
pas rester en première ligne aujourd'hui
il semble donc sûr de son bon droit ils
parlent de là
ird et le doute des dossiers qui va
traiter et du rétablissement de l'état
de droit mais alors parler de l'avenir
c'est peut-être aussi évoqué des dégâts
causés par cette affaire dans les
milieux policiers politique en corse
c'est à mon avis parler de l'avenir
c'est aussi gérer la crise parce que
qu'est-ce qui est qu'est-ce qui est en
crise aujourd'hui ici encore c'est
l'état de droit qui a été déstabilisée
qui a été décrédibilisée
on attend beaucoup des suites de
l'enquète parce que il faut quand même
s'en rendre compte l'enquète a dit
beaucoup de choses elle a mis elle a mis
sous écrou pour l'instant trois
gendarmes mais elle n'a toujours pas dit
pourquoi ces trois gendarmes si les
faits sont avérés
or hitachi comme cela pour quoi il
aurait monté cette opération et surtout
pour le compte de qui merci michel
l'actualité au kosovo tout d'abord à
belgrade ces deux belgrade aujourd'hui
que sont venues les interrogations
nouvelles sur les possibilités d'une
issue politique ou diplomatique au
conflit engagé depuis le 24 mars le vice
ministre de slobodan milosevic monsieur
vu que dans the beach qui fut longtemps
un opposant a fait entendre sa
différence il affirme que la fédération
yougoslave est disposé à ce qu'une force
de l'onu soit déployée au kosovo
à paris le président chirac s'est
déclarée sceptique et comme lui les pays
membres de l'alliance atlantique ont des
doutes sur la solidité des positions
exprimées par monsieur luc dragovic
explications avec jean marc et 12 il
vice-premier ministre de yougoslavie
mais depuis 48 heures il s'exprime comme
s'il était redevenu chef de l'opposition
question vous grâce kovic parle-t-il
avec ou sans l'accord tacite du
président milosevic
quand il suggère ce qu'a toujours refusé
ce dernier le déploiement d'une force de
l'onu au kosovo de préférence sans les
pays de l'otan dit il mais deuxième
surprise vaudra ce kovic ne ferme pas te
fais la porte quand ils ajoutent selon
lui pas nous avons aussi l'obligation de
respecter les résolutions du conseil de
sécurité des nations unies et d'affirmer
que ses propos actuels vont globalement
dans le sens du compromis pour l'instant
mal connus passé entre le numéro un
serbe et l'envoyé spécial russe la
semaine dernière à belgrade
un ballon d'essai officieux ou geste
véritable de défi à l'égard de slobodan
milosevic
il faut savoir que l'ex écrivain
nationaliste devenu politicien est un
habitué des coups de tête entre 93 et 95
il organisera les seules manifestations
qui dénonceront les excès des milices
serbes en croatie puis en bosnie en 97
il fédérera un moment le mouvement
d'opposition d'une serbie appauvris par
seguer et assoiffés de liberté
d'expression mais en 98 au nom de
l'union sacrée autour du kosovo woogie
draskovic n'écoutera que son ambition
pour se rallier à slobodan milosevic
voilà pourquoi aujourd'hui les
déclarations tonitruantes du vice
premier ministre serbe sont accueillis à
paris avec attention mais avec prudence
c'est un premier signe ça promet si
intéressant parce que il mentionne le
rôle des nations unies et le règlement
pacifique de cet horrible conflit
maintenant question est ce que cette
position est soutenue par l'ensemble des
responsables a b g et deuxième question
est ce que les responsables de belgrade
sont prêts à passer des paroles aux
actes
aujourd'hui à belgrade de vos adresses
kovic a poursuivi son offensive
médiatique analyse de reloger rare l'un
des rares journalistes français encore à
belgrade le ballon d'essai c'est de voir
si l'otan accepterait cette force
conduite par l'onu au kosovo vous grâce
comme il y en a parlé longuement avec
l'envoyé spécial du président russe et
ils sont exactement sur la même ligne
le bouillant écrivain ministre veut
éviter la destruction totale des
infrastructures de son pays et veut
trouver une issue pour la yougoslavie et
il veut en quelque sorte forcé milosevic
à l'accepter il m'a dit
mon devoir est de lui apporter les
munitions et son devoir de président et
de les accepter
le président boris eltsine adressé un
message de soutien slobodan milosevic ce
dernier affiche toujours la même
silhouette impassible malgré les
derniers bombardements des structures de
l'otan commentaires françois corner en
ce 7e anniversaire de la création de la
nouvelle yougoslavie de slobodan
milosevic le président de la fédération
vêtu de son éternel imperméable bleu
marine à gizeh exceptionnellement et
pour la première fois aujourd'hui son
palais présidentiel pour déposer une
gerbe sur la tombe du soldat inconnu
même souci du détail comme tito même
cérémonial
malgré le bruit des bombes sur belgrade
chef de guerre sans uniforme slobodan
milosevic n'a rien perdu semble-t-il de
sa détermination en l'honneur de
l'héroïsme du peuple yougoslave contre
l'agresseur est en l'honneur de son
combat pour la liberté signée slobodan
milosevic
quelques heures avant cette cérémonie
l'immeuble abritant le siège du parti
socialiste au pouvoir du président
yougoslave avait été touché pour la
seconde fois par deux missiles dont l'un
a détruit l'émetteur assurant la
diffusion de plusieurs chaînes de
télévision à belgrade
installé sur le toit du gratte-ciel de
23 étages d'autres raids ont été menés
la nuit dernière sur l'abeille bodine et
le kosovo en marge de cette guerre une
autre image
hier soir les américains ont perdu sept
hélicoptères anti char apache qui
effectué des manoeuvres dans le nord de
l'albanie à une cinquantaine de
kilomètres de tirana à la suite d'une
avarie mécanique l'appareil descente en
autorotation et s'écrase au sol avant de
s'enflammer
la bâche et par des domiciles qui
n'explose rompt pas le pilote et le
tireur consistant à l'équipage son ex
près de la carlingue en feu
légèrement blessé nous allons les voir
dans un instant ce crash a été filmé en
direct par une caméra infrarouge de
l'armée américaine qui enregistrait ses
manoeuvres
un accident qui ne remettra pas en cause
l'engagement des apaches prévu pour
cette semaine contre les blindés et la
retirer
serbes au kosovo aujourd'hui à bonn le
ministre allemand de la défense a
présenté à la presse des documents
illustrant les exactions commises par
les forces de police serbes dans le
village de rue govou au kosovo le 29
janvier dernier
quelques semaines avant la conférence de
rambouillet deux mois avant le début des
frappes contre la yougoslavie des
documents éloquent sur les atrocités
commises contre les kosovars
ces photos auraient été prises par un
lieutenant allemand qui se trouvait à
l'époque au kosovo en tant
qu'observateur de l'eau à eux
les états unis vont mobiliser 33000
réservistes pour appuyer la campagne de
l'otan contre la yougoslavie les
premiers renforts de soldats
britanniques sont attendus à la fin de
la semaine prochaine et ce sont des
mirages des forces françaises qui ont
participé la nuit dernière aux
différentes missions de frappes
aériennes aujourd'hui sur la base
d'istres anna en italie ont pratiqué une
opération de communication
reportage alain de chalvron dominique
merlet
22h15 un groupe de pilotes de mirage
2000d se dirigent vers leur appareil
les mécaniciens vérifie une dernière
fois les systèmes d'armes l'électronique
et toute la bonne marche de l'avion
quand il s'installe dans le cockpit
ces pilotes sont déjà sept ou huit
heures de travail de préparation
derrière eux le stress disparaît un
petit peu derrière une succession
d'actes techniques
c'est désormais leur métier qu'ils font
et ils le font jusqu'au bout ils ont pas
est bien sûr les risques ces risques
précisément ils ont été évalués dans les
moindres détails pendant les heures de
préparation par le chef de patrouille et
son navigateur
tout a été évalué une fois la mission
des gages droite 450 au monté à 20
heures un dernier briefing conduit par
les deux hommes pour devant les autres
pilotes au change et bien sûr ne fournit
qu'une version édulcorée a recalé les
aspects principaux de la mission en
défense en attaque d'un poste de
commandement durci sur mer en plein
coeur de la servie le mirage 2000d
spécialisée dans l'attaqué au sol de
nuit c'est ce que l'on fait de mieux
dans l'armée de l'air française rend ce
type d'armement est parfaitement adapté
à l'objectif qui vient de lui être fixés
objectifs approuvés en haut lieu
tous les objectifs que nous assigne
l'alliance sont examinés par mes
collaborateurs et moi même qui s'en suit
ils sont remontés au niveau du niveau
politique pour approuver tous ses choix
d'objectifs à 23h15 une heure après
l'installation des pilotes dans leur
copie les mirage 2000d
ce soir d'école bear l'ours
les missiles sol air sont toujours
actifs il ya toujours un nom et donc les
laisse partir toujours avec beaucoup
d'émotion c'est avec un très très grand
plaisir de le voir redescendre ce sera
fait à 1h30 du matin après 2h15 de vol
les appareils non plus leurs bombes sous
le fuselage mission apparemment
accomplie en macédoine les militaires
français qui font partie des forces de
l'otan ont décidé de prendre des mesures
de précaution supplémentaires après un
attentat commis contre l'un de leurs
sites hier soir à kumanovo dans le
nord-ouest du pays les français sont
près de la frontière et dans une zone
les villageois macédonienne ne sont pas
favorables aux frappes de l'otan
reportage richard binet patrick desmulie
nous sommes à bord d'un blindé français
au nord de la macédoine à cinq
kilomètres de la frontière du boss là il
y a quelques jours encore c'était une
patrouille de routine mais depuis
l'attentât de la nuit dernière contre un
centre logistique de l'armée française
les militaires sont sur leurs gardes en
tête du convoi
le capitaine le sieur il est arrivé
avant le début de la guerre
mais depuis la situation a radicalement
changé de l'otan début des frappes de
l'otan on a pu constater que les
certaine radicalisation la position des
des gens en macédoine les gens qui
étaient pro serbes se sont manifesté une
certaine hostilité l'égard de l'action
de l'otan
pour ce qui est comment dire que les
albanais un certain enthousiasme un
mauvais gars ces images ne doivent pas
faire illusion
les villages que nous traversons sont à
majorité albanaise pour éviter toute
provocation
l'armée française ne pénètrent plus dans
les régions dominées par les serbes de
macédoine sur notre chemin un seul arrêt
possible
le petit village albanais d'ohrid sary
heureusement que les forces de l'otan
sont là ça serait très dangereux pour
nous sinon on remercie l'europe et
l'otan qui nous protège milosevic ou
piller tout grâce à dieu les forces de
l'otan sont arrivées on espère que tout
va s'arranger
le long de la frontière avec le kosovo
l'armée française poursuit son
entraînement pour faire face à toute
éventualité
une attaque serbe mais surtout une
action terroriste
au début des frappes aériennes de l'otan
nous avions envisagé plusieurs menaces
parmi lesquels un tir d'artillerie de
représailles sur kumanovo ou une attaque
plus ou moins forte de chars dans cette
plaine de kumanovo et puis il y avait
bien entendu la menace terroriste qui
était la plus plausible et qui
effectivement est arrivé hier nous
avions donc pris un certain nombre de
mesures pour nous en prémunir
ces mesures ont fonctionné il n'ya donc
pas lieu d'en changer il ya simplement
lieu d'avoir beaucoup de vigilance pour
continuer à les appliquer
éviter toute provocation c'est la
consigne donnée aux soldats français
car si dans les villages à majorité
albanaise que nous avons traversé les
forces de l'otan font figure de
libérateur dans d'autres villages on
parle déjà de force d'occupation
le premier ministre monsieur lionel
jospin doit se rendre en macédoine et en
albanie à la fin de cette semaine dans
une longue déclaration faite devant
l'assemblée nationale cet après midi il
a écarté une intervention seul au kosovo
mais a ajouté que si cette intervention
était décidée bien il solliciterait un
vote des parlementaires
monsieur jospin d'autre part expliqué
que l'efficacité de la stratégie
actuelle de l'otan s'apprécierait avec
le temps
l'épuration ethnique était programmé
décidé et avait commencé aucune
stratégie ne pouvait garantir qu'elle
soit arrêtée pas plus une intervention
terrestre à haut risque qui aurait vu
s'étendre sans doute la pratique des
boucliers humains
pas plus le renoncement à toute action
qui aurait laissé libre cours à ses
activités criminelles à vouloir la paix
sans les frappes on aurait eu
l'épuration ethnique sans les bombes
c'est à dire sans que le régime serbe
n'en paie au moins le prix
l'efficacité de la stratégie arrêtée ne
pourra s'apprécier qu'avec le temps vous
savez que notre détermination est
entière
monsieur milosevic devra céder selon le
général américain wesley clark le
commandant suprême des forces de l'otan
en europe il y aurait actuellement à
l'intérieur du kosovo environ huit cent
vingt mille personnes déplacées ces
tablettes chez la frontière macédonienne
que 5000 nouveaux réfugiés albanais sont
arrivées aux postes frontières de l'ue
faisant du embarquée après avoir
beaucoup attendu sen sont embarqués sans
doute vers le sud du pays mais on ne
sait pas très bien où les informations
sont très difficiles à obtenir
à ce poste frontière de blatche et en
macédoine parmi les dizaines de milliers
de réfugiés des enfants le reportage qui
va suivre deux clubs sans père et
dernier auprès de cook est en albanie a
été réalisé en compagnie de l'unicef
mais surtout parmi des enfants plus de
la moitié des 110 mille réfugiés
installé tant bien que mal à couches un
coup kech au moins de 15 ans ils sont
pleins de récits d'horreur plein d'image
de détresse il leur faut donc en plus du
gîte et du couvert des sourires et des
jeux
jeu est très simple chaque enfant doit
donner son prénom et relancer le ballon
c'est une des techniques utilisées par
l'unicef pour aider ces enfants de
réfugiés effacer les traces de la guerre
pour les aider à retrouver la parole et
le sourire à travers des jeux et des
chants jour après jour il arrive tout
doucement oublier ce qu'ils viennent de
vivre
susanna à 9 ans elle vient d'arriver
je suis venu avec mon grand père ma
grand-mère et ma mère je suis venu avec
mes frères et mes soeurs williams ni
vendeur ou tuer installés ici tout près
dans la maison voilà laisser jouer tu
veux parler quel est ton histoire et
attrape la gauche laurent est ici depuis
plus longtemps
on peut le deviner rien qu'en entendant
le ton savoie je m'appelle laura maes
des coups je viens de ville adopté
rocher ici on est bien mais on a
beaucoup souffert
nous on s'est sauvés avant il ya
plusieurs mois avec qui tu es venu avec
ma mère ma grand mère et mon nom et les
autres ils sont en allemagne
au revoir tous les jours vers un
parcours les différents camps de cocker
elle a commencé son travail il y a une
semaine avec trois autres volontaires de
l'unicef et des tout petits moyens
90 autres bénévoles de l'unicef
spécialement formés au traitement des
traumatismes chez les enfants devraient
bientôt venir l'aider dans sa tâche
après une semaine de travail est ce que
vous avez déjà vu ses enfants évoluer
oui bien sûr au début surtout les
premiers jours ils n'étaient pas aussi
nombreux autour de nous et se contente
de nous écouter maintenant ils viennent
nous voir ils parlent
on doit même parfois les freiner un peu
parce qu'il nous demande toujours
d'autres joueurs les premiers jours ça
n'arrivait jamais alors que vers 1
poursuit son travail avec les enfants
sous le regard de quelques vieux
réfugiés il se passe soudain quelque
chose dans le camp des forces de police
viennent d'arriver
elle annonce à tous ces réfugiés qu'ils
vont devoir partir dans des camps plus
éloignée de la frontière on ne leur
donne aucune destination verra viendra
discuter avec le chef de la police en
vain elle comprend très vite qu'elle
jouera plus avec son petit groupe
à peine le temps de pleurer dans la
voiture vers un retard déjà vers un
autre clan ou d'autres enfants
l'attendent
voilà pour l'actualité au kosovo ce soir
et je vous annonce que jeudi soir envoyé
spécial évoquera dans un reportage
exceptionnel de jacques merino la
situation des serbes à belgrade en
algérie prestation de serment pour
monsieur abdelaziz bouteflika
officiellement élu président de la
république son prédécesseur monsieur ben
yamin 0 h ou à passer le pouvoir
monsieur bouteflika a insisté dans son
discours du président sur la nécessité
d'une réconciliation nationale en
grande-bretagne émotion populaire très
vive après l'assassinât d'une
journaliste présentatrice vedette de la
bbc
gildan d'eau a été tué ou plutôt
exécutés d'une balle dans la tête tirée
à bout portant elle présentait une
émission qui s'intéressait aux faits
divers en demandant aux citoyens anglais
de collaborer avec la police sont
assassinés peut-être un acte de
vengeance c'est en tout cas l'une des
nombreuses pistes suivies par les
enquêteurs
correspondance depuis londres d' etienne
leenhardt c'est une rue discrète dans
l'un des quartiers les plus aisés de la
capitale britannique depuis 24 heures
des dizaines de policiers fouilles
centimètre par centimètre à la recherche
du moindre indice pouvant les mettre sur
une piste depuis que gilles dando l'une
des vedettes de la bbc a été assassiné
d'une balle dans la tête à bout portant
devant son domicile la grande bretagne
ne parle plus que de ça sa chaîne relais
du matin au soir les appels à témoin que
scotland yard ne cesse de lancer un
homme a été vu quittant les lieux
à l'heure du meurtre deschamps se
souviennent forcément de cette personne
qui était bien habillé qui avait un
portable avec lui en permanence
qu'est ce qu'il a fait après à qu'il
était absente son travail et qu'il
rentrait chez lui
outre l'acte d'un déséquilibré l'une des
pistes privilégiées par les enquêteurs
passent par cette émission à motché
programme à l'américaine sur des crimes
non résolus que gilles dando présenté
depuis cinq ans en quelques années grâce
à la collaboration du public 400
arrestations ont été opérées par les
policiers et la présentatrice pourrait
avoir été victime d'une vengeance
rares sont les britanniques qui n'ont
pas été ému par le décès d'une personne
qui faisait un peu partie de leur
famille rares sont ceux qui comprendrait
que son assassinat ne soit pas un jour
élucidées et les policiers de se
retrouver à enquêter sur le meurtre
d'une personne qui aura passé les cinq
dernières années de sa vie
professionnelle à tenter d'élucider par
télévision interposée les meurtres que
la police elle-même n'avait pas pu
résoudre la détermination des enquêteurs
de scotland yard pour arrêter le
meurtrier de gildan d'eau devrait s'en
trouver renforcée l' incendie
extrêmement rapide d'un collège à royan
dimanche provoque de très vives
inquiétudes dans les milieux de parents
d'élèves ou d'enseignants en charente
maritime
le collège a été bâtie selon le type
pailleron et on se souvient du drame
survenu il ya 26 ans dans un
établissement similaire et or il reste
beaucoup de collèges type pailleron
aussi peu sûr en france
enquête à royan françois privat et
philippe ritaine en moins d'une demi
heure
la totalité de ce collège de type
pailleron s'est embrasée heureusement
lincendie s'est déroulée dimanche matin
il n'a fait aucune victime les 800
élèves étaient en week-end
vous voyez ces ruines vous pensez à quoi
tu pensais les élèves qui j'étais pas
s'il aurait pu sortir s'il fait vite
pris pendant les heures de cours 6
février 1973
vingt personnes dont 16 enfants trouvent
la mort dans la catastrophe du cs
pailleron à paris aujourd'hui en france
il subsiste environ 300 établissements
scolaires à ossature métallique
lincendie de royan soulève à nouveau les
questions de sécurité dans de telles
structures comme ce collège de marennes
distants de quelques kilomètres
il doit être prochainement rénové ce qui
s'est passé dimanche nous fait bien sûr
nous interroger je suis là pour
témoigner des ondes de l'émotion
ressentie
quant aux questions que l'on peut se
poser à la lumière de ce qui s'est passé
dimanche
ce qu'on demande à l'heure actuelle
maintenant ce serait une reconstruction
de tous ces collèges à ossatures
métalliques parce que finalement
malheureusement l'actualité démontre que
on peut pas leur faire confiance depuis
1986 et la loi de décentralisation
ce sont les conseils généraux et
régionaux qui financent respectivement
collèges et lycées des budgets lourd
construire un collège pour 800 élèves
outre entre 60 et 80 millions de francs
la procédure de rénovation construction
d'un collège
ces deux ans donc c'est neymar londres
on peut pas on peut pas raccourcir les
délais puisque vous avez le code des
marchés publics qui vous impose des
contraintes il faut les respecter
vingt-six ans après pailleron les choses
avancent lentement c'est seulement
depuis 1994 que les pouvoirs publics ont
investi 14 milliards de francs pour la
sécurité dans les établissements à
risques jose insuffisante pour de
nombreuses associations
il faut en finir une fois pour toutes
être tranquille construire en dur
les bâtiments qui remplace ses bâtiments
et qu'on en parle enfin plus et qu'on se
retrouve pas l'année prochaine avec à
nous tous ensemble en parlant d'un
nouvel incendie solution retenue ici à
rochefort où le vieux collège émile-zola
de type pailleron cédera sa place dès la
rentrée à de nouveaux bâtiments flambant
neufs
coût de l'opération 65 millions de
francs le prix de la sécurité trafic
sncf légèrement perturbé aujourd'hui en
raison d'une grève des agents de
conduite le trafic tgv sera assuré
normalement indique la direction pour
demain et pour les trains en région
parisienne les prévisions font état d'un
sur deux ou d'un sur trois hangars d'une
heure de l'est de la gare de lyon
mais si un numéro de téléphone que vous
pouvez noter pour obtenir de plus amples
renseignements de la sncf numéro vert 0
800 15 24 24 pour ces perturbations de
trafic demain en raison d'une grève le
ministère de l'économie annonce une
baisse des tarifs de distribution du gaz
et de l'électricité à partir du 1er mai
les économies pour lés particuliers
serait de 2% environ
l'explication agnès monte
le ministère de l'industrie n'a pas
tardé pour annoncer la bonne nouvelle à
partir du mois prochain le gaz baissera
de 5 % que tous les clients et
l'électricité de 2% pour les
particuliers cette nouvelle baisse
tarifaire est la plus importante pour
gaz de france depuis dix ans elle
permettrait de réduire de plus de 200
francs par an la facture moyenne d'un
foyer
l'explication est simple les prix du gaz
sont sans cesse alignés sur ceux du
pétrole aujourd'hui très bas du côté
d'edf les basses sont régulières en
quinze ans le prix de l'électricité pour
le grand public a fondu de près de 20%
cette électricité revient donc de moins
en moins cher les coûteuses centrales
nucléaires sont aujourd'hui amorti une
baisse qui tombe à pic dans un contexte
d'ouverture des marchés européens à la
concurrence pour le grand public
la france est parmi les plus compétitifs
derrière le royaume uni et devant
l'allemagne et l'italie
mais attention l'ouverture en france ne
profitera pour l'instant fort aux
entreprises actuellement les entreprises
les grands consommateurs y gagne les
consommateurs leur situation est très
divers noms certains états membres
oh oui ils ont déjà gagné dans d'autres
états membres comme la france
ils devront attendre attendre donc
l'ouverture totale d'edf sur le marché
européen
une ouverture qui n'est pas encore
programmée
football demi finale de la coupe de
france ce soir à sedan les ardennais
reçoivent le mans et demain à nantes les
canaris seront opposés à nîmes club de
deuxième division l'occasion pour nous
d'évoquer la qualité développée par le
jeu nantais c'est toute une école qui a
déjà formé et touré 49e desailly à miss
henri michel que sais-je encore le reste
est l'actuel et bien vous ai présenté
maintenant par florent gautreau et
thierry breton ici tout n'est que luxe
calme et volupté la jonelière un petit
paradis en pays nantais abrite l'un des
centres de formation les plus
performants de france
les plus jeunes ont 13 ans et rêve de
s'entraîner sur le terrain des pros
comme mickaël landreau
pur produit du club landreau illustre à
merveille la réussite du système nantais
à 20 ans il a déjà joué 90 matchs en
première division et garde les buts de
l'équipe de france espoirs quand on est
jeune l'envié qu'on a c'est de devenir
professionnel mais pour moi c'était pas
une session particulière
ce qui était important c'était de
pouvoir continuer mes études à côté du
football et gravir les échelons
normalement au niveau scolaire y en a
qui appelle ça des sacrifices pour moi
c'était de la normalité pour pouvoir
réussir c'est une école au milieu des
terrains c'est l'un des secrets du bel
équilibre nantais 123 sportif de 18
disciplines partagent leur temps entre
les études et l'entraînement un oeil sur
les cahiers l'autre sur le ballon
michael a connu ça pendant trois ans la
jonelière est une pépinière où l'on
protège les talents naissants si dans la
vie extérieure au football on leur
laisse pas d'initiative et on en laisse
pas de liberté je vois pas comment on
pourrait leur demander d'en avoir sur le
terrain
donc c'est vrai qu' on essaie aussi de
les rendre responsables dans leurs dans
la gestion de leur vie extra football on
l'est on les guide sens sans choisir à
leur place
cette liberté on la retrouve dans le jeu
nantais dès le plus jeune âge liberté et
générosité
le déplacement est synonyme de
disponibilité la passe de solidarité
les éducateurs l'avouent ils préfèrent
perdre avec leurs idées plutôt que
gagner en les trahissent et ça marche
en 95 nantes devient champion de france
pour la septième fois de son histoire en
pratiquant un football de rêve
joueur n'oublie jamais leur passage à
nantes quand tu nous quittes il s'est
déroulé ils chercheront tout le temps à
transmettre ce qu'ils ont éprouvé le
plaisir qu'ils ont ici n'est ils
chercheront de transmettre donc sans ça
on peut parler d'école mais il y en a
d'autres aussi mais c'est vrai qu'on
n'est plus reconnu à travers le jeu et à
travers on peut dire le collectif
l'école nantaise et ses fleurons de
sailly et des chants aux fusées leurs
crampons en pays nantais avant de
conquérir le monde
l'exemple est parfait la voie est tracée
landreau a été formé pour leur
ressembler nous arriverons à la fin de
ce journal avant de le refermer je vous
appelle deux informations que nous avons
développée en corse de bord la mise en
examen et l'emprisonnement de trois
gendarmes dont un colonel après la
destruction d'un restaurant de plage
près d'ajaccio suscite beaucoup
d'interrogations sur l'état de droit
fait l'hôte évolue par le préfet bernard
bonnet celui ci a été reçu par mise
intérieur qui refuse d'évoquer sa
démission de monsieur bonnet est rentrée
ce soir à ajaccio au kosovo les frappes
de l'otan continue monsieur jospin
écartent pour l'instant une intervention
terrestre à belgrade le dise premier
ministre vu brasco beach affirme que son
pays est prêt pour le déploiement des
forces de l'onu au kosovo dans quelques
secondes la météo de nathalie rihouet
puis vous allez voir la cohérence de la
soirée à 20h55 la vache et le prisonnier
avec fernandel à 23h10 la vie à
l'endroit de magazines de marins de
mireille dumas s'intéressera à l'animal
en vedette
et puis à 0 heure quarante-cinq vous
trouvez pour le dernier journal florence
dupré a suivi du cercle de philippe
lefait demain à 7h50 dans les 4 vérités
michael farkas recevra alain la ville
auteur du livre un crime politique en
corse et puis à 13h vous retrouverez
rachid arhab à demain 20h bonsoir merci